I'm employed here at the University of
Manchester not only in the Department of
Earth atmospheric and environmental
sciences where a lecture as where I
teach my courses on vertebrate
paleontology and evolution I'm also
based here at the Manchester Museum and
here is where I do a lot of my research
on the wonderful collections there is
something in a region of 4 million
objects held within the collections here
at the managed Museum it is museum
that's been existent since the latter
half of the 19th century four years ago
we brought Stan the t-rex to Manchester
you'd be surprised to know that it came
in boxes it took us two hours to build
and it was sort of self-assembly there's
over 200 bones in the skeleton of stan
and we've got to fit them together into
what is a dynamic running pose this is
based upon the research that we're doing
here at the University of Manchester we
put the running speed of Tyrannosaurus
Rex but approximately 18 miles per hour
that's as fast as a pro footballer can
run that's quite respectable for an
animal that probably weighed in between
five and seven and a half tons
over the past two years we've tried very
hard at the University of Manchester to
bring in new techniques into
paleontology so it's not so much a bunch
of folks at the bottom of a hole digging
for bones anymore that's just part of
the story we want to take it to the next
stage the next level in terms of
understanding of these wonderful fossils
we pull from the ground the key thing is
that these fossils can tell us so much
about these extinct organisms and by
studying the bones and studying the
associated sediments the associated
evidence treating I suppose a dig site
like a scene of a crime we were able to
piece together these shreds of evidence
to a much more coherent story of what
life was like in the prehistoric past of
the planet a lot of the methods that we
use here at the University of Manchester
are quite unique to this department we
have tried very hard to have an
interdisciplinary approach where I'm not
just working with other geologists and
paleontologists but engineers physicists
chemists and they're all bringing their
own particular skills to the science of
paleontology
so it's a very exciting time to be a
paleontologist for the simple reason
we're looking into areas of science now
which we felt the doors previously
closed firmly shut to our own particular
field of science it's becoming very
apparent but this is not the case
you